a surreal day in American history former
president Donald Trump on his way back
to Florida after surrendering himself at
a Manhattan Courthouse he was arrested
fingerprinted and pled not guilty to 34
felony counts of falsifying business
records we're expecting to hear from
president Trump later tonight Ron Janice
is outside the courthouse in lower
Manhattan to break down the charges
Prime
Jesse good evening that's right so
former president Trump charged with 34
felony counts of falsifying business
records here in the state of New York
just moments ago well about a couple
hours ago the district attorney of
Manhattan Alvin Bragg laid out his case
listen
Donald Trump was arraigned on a New York
Supreme Court indictment returned by a
Manhattan grand jury
on 34 felony counts of falsifying
business records in the first degree
under New York state law is a felony
to falsify business records with intent
of Fraud and an intent to conceal
another crime
that is exactly what this case is about
so D.A Bragg is charging former
president Trump with 34 felony counts
that's a felony count for every single
falsified business record that they have
in evidence apparently now as he
mentioned in New York in order to be
found guilty of a felony counter be
charged with the felony count you have
to be found to have been trying to hide
or a second crime so in this case what
Bragg is alleging is that essentially
former president Trump falsified
business records in furtherance of his
2016 presidential election which is a
violation of New York state election law
because under New York state election
law you can't be promoting a candidate
or your candidacy under unlawful means
that's as best as we have as we see it
based on his press conference in terms
of understanding the charges now in
terms of what happened inside the
courtroom the former president did not
say a word he sat stoically our
courtroom producer Jake Gibson says that
at one point he described the former
president walking into the courtroom
with swagger he stared down Alvin Bragg
before he left that courtroom he
verbally pleaded not guilty to all 34
counts there were two big motions that
happened inside that courtroom one was
about timing the other was about a
potential gag order the prosecution
bringing up posts on Truth social that
the former president had posted that
they believed could have incited
violence and they essentially asked or
requested this judge to issue a gag
order at least they
um they implied that they wanted one and
in that case judge Juan Merchant said
that he was going to request that Trump
not further post things that could
incite violence and that if he were then
that they would revisit that request and
the second big thing that happened
inside there was about timing the
prosecution asking for this case to be
pushed all the way to January which
would be right at the heart and the
start of the Republican primary election
season the defense wanted this case to
be pushed back even further they found
that this case this well now the next
hearing will now be December 4th and
that former president Trump must be here
in person the defense argued why should
the former president be here in person
you can understand the undue burden that
that has put on the city of New York
that argument rang on deaf ears and
judge Juan Merchant said the former
president needs to be here December 4th
for the next hearing Jesse Ryan thanks
so much uh Judge Jeanine Pierre you
spent some time in the courtroom uh how
do you see things developing today well
I'll start with the last thing that uh
that was just said and that is that the
defendant needs to be present on I
believe it was December 4th if I if I
have the date right
that is ridiculous because uh it is only
a hearing to submit motions or to get a
decision on motions okay it is
ministerial it's where the prosecutor
the judge and the defense attorney get
together and there is either a decision
issued on the motion or there is a the
discussion that they'll argue the
Motions but the over all response that I
have to all of this is it's less
significant than I thought it would be
in the first place this is a whole lot
of nothing and you know defense
attorneys have done that in every case I
ever tried as a prosecutor and I never
thought I'd do it to an indictment
myself first of all the indictment is
insufficient on its face what that means
is that the prosecutor does not allege
what the other crime is so he's saying
he falsified records with intent to
commit another crime we don't know what
the other crime is and even Alvin
bragged when he was asked about it said
well we had evidence this time that they
didn't have last time as it related to
why now but in addition to that we've
got election law and we've got uh text
messages and emails what are you talking
about why not identify the crime that is
giving you the ability to take a dead
misdemeanor and give it New Life Like a
Phoenix rising out of the uh out of the
sand now if anyone looks at this
indictment they will realize also that
in the addition to being insufficient on
its face it is duplicitous and what that
means is they've got if you look at the
first four counts they all occurred on
February 14th of Feb of 2017. that means
you've got the same course of conduct
they're just looking at it differently
okay so nobody get excited about the 34
clowns they're meaningless and there
will also be a bill of particulars in
the Bill of particulars which is
required to be submitted in New York
state within 15 days it may be extended
to 35 if the judge wants to give the D.A
a break they've got to be real clear on
what the bill in particular says because
the defendant has the right to uh
prepare for trial and this is garbage
you don't have a right to prepare you
don't know what to prepare for on this
and by the way you know the the whole
concept that Brad gets up and he talks
about you know this is New York we are
the center of the financial world and
all that hogwash doesn't explain saying
why he takes every felony he can find
fifty percent at the bare minimum and
turns it into misdemeanors but wants
this misdemeanor to be a felony and why
did the defense have to come back why
does Michael law uh why does Donald
Trump have to come back in December when
it's going to cost New York City
millions of dollars and any prosecutor
would consider the cost to the city or
the county in deciding whether or not
the appearance of the defendant is
necessary and uh I mean I could go on
but well should we hear from the other
lawyer at the table we got one sitting
right here would you like to say
anything about what the judge just
asserted
so this is a tough day I think any time
and I watched I watched the president's
face as he left Trump Tower and I
watched him as he the pictures that we
saw she said a live picture of him
walking into the courtroom and then the
picture that they took in the courtroom
of him two or three times and it's first
time I'd ever seen I don't know the
president that well I know him
personally but I'd never seen him look
that way it is obvious the weight of the
moment it was serious for him so you
look at him in the humanity of of the
situation certainly screams at you
whether you like his politics or not you
cannot help but understand what that
picture connoted two I I agree with the
judge New York law as the judge knows
does not require
if you cite a federal law for you to
actually if you say a federal law was
broken you don't have to cite it however
uh Dave Bragg should have cited what the
federal law what the federal law is he's
he's playing it by the book here and I
think but in light of the fact this is
the former president of the United
States this is a matter uh that uh on
the face we know that we believe the
southern district of of New York the U.S
attorney's Office passed on some of this
the former D.A side Vance his office
passed on some of this so I think the
burden whether it's fair or not was
higher on the district attorney to lay
some of these things out now as you read
the indictment it is it reads like a
daytime soap opera uh in so many ways
the things that that and we knew a lot
of these things from 2016 and voters
were aware of some of the allegations uh
that uh from some of these some of the
women that were that that are talked
about the two women that are talked
about in this and we all know what
Michael Cohen did I think the question
now uh I think for the president and his
legal team is how quickly do they want
to go forward with this meaning they
will file the requisite motions to
dismiss it'll be interesting to see how
the judge reacts I'm going to assume his
lawyers are going to lay out that these
matters were passed on by two other
legal offices including the U.S
attorney's office so be curious to see
how this judge handles it one thing I do
hope we all are able to accept is that
our judicial system works and this judge
here will have an opportunity to weigh
all of these facts to weigh the Motions
which I assume will come to Mr Trump's
attorneys have not consulted with me but
I assume that they're going to file
these motions and I expect this judge
who seems to want to move quickly
December 4th doesn't seem quick enough
to me but I would assume that President
Trump former president Trump would want
it to move quickly and I would assume
the judge you take him at his word that
he wants to consider all these motions
uh quickly on a personal level I was
expecting a little more Jesse
I was expecting a little more in it at a
minimum I do hope at some point that the
district attorney here in New York will
tell us what that other crime what what
the other Federalists do in the bill in
particulars well so I hope I hope I was
I was disappointed judge he didn't do it
there that's all my point and I'd hope
that he does it before uh before too
long and Harris the president right now
is in route to Mar-A-Lago or he will be
addressing many people tonight at 8 15
we believe
um I want to take this kind of unpack
this in backwards order here so the file
motions will come in August that's when
the defense can can move on that
um December 4th I had some thoughts
about that judge they didn't get what
they wanted
they were hoping that it was going to be
crazy
and that judge was going to be able to
slap on a gag order and and you've been
cited and you've done all that and he
was buttoned up because the Secret
Service handled him
you didn't see the cuff she didn't see
any of that they set the rules they set
the tone they protected him and so they
didn't get the circus that that you know
I was on when that news conference
happened yesterday with uh with the
police commissioner and mayor Eric Adams
and how you know we're getting ready and
and to to congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green you better be on your best
behavior and all this kind of stuff and
I mean talk about incitement why don't
you just you know throw some gasoline
where there is no fire and then hope it
Sparks
um but a couple of things I I caught
what you were talking about I try to be
the judge sometimes think like her uh in
the eighth count I I caught what you
were talking about in the first four I
saw some dates like April 13 2017.
that's a loaded date they're gonna do a
lot with that date and I don't have your
Acumen as a judge or legal expert but
when I looked at that I thought oh
there's something else they're going to
need they're going to need Michael Cohen
how important is heat of this case oh a
criminal liar a criminal liar and that
seems critical because that would really
show just what Harold said nothing is
new in this case
they're going backward to the person
that they know tells the most lies gets
away with it until he didn't legally
and that date April 13 2017 we've
already seen him in the in the Access
Hollywood video with Billy Bush and all
that that's in here I didn't understand
how that fit with a white collar crime
which Alvin Bragg says that's the kind
of crime that New York City
attorneys go after district attorney
said well I'm glad I know the kind of
crime he goes after because violent
crime is rampant so at least there's
something that he's going to fight
and then the last thought I had was
what do you say to the crowd tonight at
701 this morning
many of us in the media got the make
America great again Inc email
which said
president Trump is the clear
front-runner in 2024 Republican
presidential primary and it laid out
taking a look at New Hampshire
registered voters Trump 42 DeSantis 29
and then everybody else who's running
they started the day with politics he
can talk about that now if he wants sure
I I would imagine you would tell him you
would tell him as attorneys
yeah I wouldn't talk about this case
because that judge I think meant he's
waiting for the circus you didn't bring
it but he will slap a gag order on you
so there's an opportunity tonight I'm
curious no is he going to go this route
talk about inflation prices how he's
going to save America
where is he going to go I think that's
the biggest part of the day so I
actually was
surprised by the lack of their there in
the news conference by the district
attorney
who obviously was thinking he was on his
come up he was going to make it big off
this case but then laid it out the way I
would as a layperson
light on the facts until maybe we can
figure out how to sell it I think I
could have sold it better oh I think we
all could have how you doing Jesse good
evening to all of you and I should be
with you this today has reminded me why
I never went to law school and I'll
leave it to the legal Minds that take us
through it just a couple observations
here for the past six days every legal
analyst we've had on this network has
said I need to see the indictment what
do you think about I need to see the
entire what are you doing for lunch I
need to see the indictment well now we
have seen the indictment and
even CNN thinks this is thin look we've
got five people around the table right
now they've had seven people around a
table since noon today and it continues
at this hour last hour that a former
Council U.S assistant AG is saying is
pretty underwhelming uh these facts have
been out there for seven years John
Bolton no friend of Donald Trump today
right he wasn't buying it he said this
complaint can easily be dismissed it's
that thin Bolton's got a legal
background as well all these comments
really surprised me quite a bit but
Harris you mentioned something about the
the reality in New York today and we can
get that throughout the hour here but I
would just remind everybody that two
weeks ago today president XI was in
Moscow meeting with Vladimir Putin yeah
for three days
about three hours
not for some photo op and red square and
the flyback to Beijing for three days
and what do you think they were talking
about you know more than just the land
borders between Russia and China that
they still have some disputes to this
day they're talking about how they're
going to divide up the world and the the
the
decisions that Muhammad did Salman MBs
is now making in Saudi Arabia about you
know a peace deal with Iran China's in
the middle of that uh he's inviting
Assad to a summit that will take place
in Saudi Arabia all this is happening
while we're watching this and he cut oil
Productions and he cut oil production to
uh to a million a day
if you're a fan of cable news look I'm a
child of cable news I grew up in it
almost 28 years and I love it but every
channel throughout the past 14 hours has
been on the Trump story
there's a lot of important matters
happening in the world outside of this
right and it was a bush League
indictment if you read it and everybody
expected more and we do expect to hear
more from the president tonight at 8 15
from Mar-A-Lago
Bill hammer well
um we will see that tonight at 8 15.
right and we'll be watching that to see
what he has to say Alvin Bragg though
the D.A here in Manhattan Jesse
defending this historic decision to
charge former president Trump at 34
counts of falsifying business records
I've been doing this for 24 years I
don't bring cases prior to a thorough
and rigas investigation now having done
so the case has been brought why now
well as I just mentioned we have had
available to the office additional
evidence that was not in the office's
possession prior to my time here the
basis for business integrity and a
well-functioning business Marketplace is
true and accurate record-keeping that's
the charge that's brought here
falsifying New York State business
records okay so Bragg's decision flies
in the face so with the American people
think about the politics of this
indictment while sixty percent say they
approve the charges an overwhelming 76
percent say politics played a role 52
percent go a step further saying it
played a major role and that poll just
came out this week back with us out here
Alvin Bragg said I think the quote was
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct and I I think you've
had 35 000 cops who haven't had a day
off since last Friday I if you want to
criminalize serious conduct come to my
neighborhood because I can show you a
ton of it my subway stop where I live
um Janine this will come back into Focus
about the reality of American cities
today and the question will be why don't
you put your attention on that because
what you've got is a woke Democrat
prosecutor
and a lot of these Democrat cities that
are not interested in the victim of
crime I've spent 32 years of my life
fighting for that crime victim and they
are now being ignored and when you get
to the point where you bring it an
indictment against a former president of
the United States running for president
again talk about you know a third world
country I mean it better be serious this
is not serious Harris said Michael
Cohen's in that indictment this guy you
can't every time he opens his mouth he's
lying whether it's Congress whether it's
on television he is a perjurer and they
want to rest the indictment on his
testimony and I got one better when they
asked him why did you wait so long why
did you wait so long he didn't have an
answer he said we have evidence that
they didn't have before hot wash after
this guy Costello came in and testified
in the grand jury saying that Michael
Cohen was a nut job and a liar who do
they bring bring back they brought back
David pecker from Ami I mean David
pecker that whole catch and and uh kill
they knew that in 2016 2015 2017.
there's nothing new here so one of the
additional charges that they can use in
this case is not just selective
prosecution but in the motion to dismiss
there is a delay and there is a recent
court of appeals case in New York in a
rape case a rape case no less where the
court of appeals said you waited too
long and and this is beyond the statute
of limitations that case was not that
case was not there was not a 30 30
problem and I won't explain it but
they've got a lot of explaining to do
this case should not get past the
sufficiency of the indictments Yes Alvin
Bragg did do one thing today Harold he
completed a campaign promise did he not
I mean when he was running for this
office he said he he was proud of the
fact that he sued Donald Trump hundreds
of times I believe is the quote he used
and that he was going to go after him
yet again and for a while there it
seemed like you couldn't even run for
office in New York unless you said I'm
going to get Trump
um today
did he take a step in that direction
uh I don't know it well he obviously
took a step because he brought an
indictment against the former president
I'd say two things one I think all the
points you made Bill about the things
that are happening around the globe we
should focus on that a lot more
everywhere uh and I think there's no
shortage of things that we sometimes
focus on in the media that we should not
because I agree with you what that Chi
that balloon that has been
misrepresented about what it was
gathering and what's happened in China
that's something we should focus on a
lot more too
um I was disappointed to dalen because I
thought Moore was going to be there but
that doesn't mean that nothing is there
uh and I think that the things that the
president's going to have to answer for
his lawyers will do that uh and he's got
seems like he's got a top-notch legal
team and
um we'll see what happens now I think
you raised a larger problem about DA's
we shouldn't elect is this woman here
was like the D.A and she may she may
have run on a platform of fighting crime
and making communities safer uh and he
did too he he made it as an element one
of the elements going after Donald Trump
uh and voters here in New York uh voted
for him I happen to believe that we
shouldn't elect judges or DA's but
that's just me I don't think that should
be a they shouldn't be out campaigning
in those offices they get there you just
want them to get there but I want to
point them like we do judges there it's
the same way politics well but so but
either way well we can we can have that
conversation too my only point is but
but you can't say he ran on a platform
that he delivered on whenever you can
but Harrison let me just finish I'll
wait for you to finish but so you can't
be critical of the fact that he did that
when that's what our process is I think
D.A should not I don't think we should
elect judges either because by
definition you know what that means that
means those offices are politicized
finally I hope tonight here someone
answered your point I think you you
raised the selling point tonight for
president Trump I hope he focuses he
entered his plea of not guilty and he is
presumed and it's at every Democrat and
Republicans you know he is innocent this
evening until and unless evidence and
facts are proven in a courtroom and a
jury believes otherwise
two I have honor him I'd focus on why I
wanted to run for president and lay out
all of the issues including some of the
things that you raise Bill about what's
happening in China including inflation
and some of those things that's what
that's why people I think are going to
going to elect him or not elect him as
the Republican nominee and eventually If
he if he uh is a nominee up against
Harris your name was invoked in a good
way was a couple things again in reverse
order I don't think you need to worry
about what Trump will figure on and and
where he's going to focus he went to
East Palestine Ohio when it was hell it
was still on fire
when did Biden go
there's I was saying you're right I
wouldn't I was an argument I think you
should say those things but I'm right
again on that part because honestly
if you look at what he's been doing
versus and we'll get into it a little
bit later in the show where is Biden is
the segment
but when you look at what he's capable
of doing he can make the tide rise if he
wants the current president hasn't been
able to do that on the economy and he's
been gone since last week
he's had a couple of gaffs he needs to
figure out where the Twisters hit in
Mississippi maybe he'll be that next
but
when you talk about Alvin Bragg and how
things are he has a choice he doesn't
have to run and say I'm going to pin
everything on going after one guy he did
that so that his staff would stop
leaving
they said you're not going to go after
Trump we're out palmerance who wrote the
book you're holding right there right
I'm out you're not going after Trump
you're breaking your campaign promise
and that's when he said well I didn't
say I wasn't going to go after him I
just want to have a better case was
today a better case yeah you're an
attorney I didn't see it I read that I
read the the statement of facts I read
the indictment uh it's pretty cut and
dry no
Jesse you have been very patient
fat Alvin's a laughing stock we were on
the edge of our seats waiting for the
D.A to come out and say he had video of
trump hiding a dead body at Trump Tower
maybe a picture of him handing a
briefcase full of cash to an election
official he had nothing he came out and
he didn't meet the moment he didn't meet
the moment and even the media knew he
didn't meet the moment because the man
couldn't sell it if you can't explain
the charge in 30 seconds
you don't have a case and the man could
not explain the charge he didn't even
put the felony charge the election
charge and the indictment and said and I
didn't really have to so to get out of
here man you're charging the former
president and you didn't even say what
the charge is come on so
he's spending how many millions of
dollars on this circus he's shutting
down the FDR Drive he's hiring how many
police officers how much Manpower is
going into the DA's office on this case
alone meanwhile you got a crime wave out
here and he has the nerve to come out
and say he doesn't want to normalize you
know crime come on man his case is built
on a disbarred lawyer who served prison
time for lying a porn actress who
actually had to pay Trump
because she lied about the NDA and
Michael avenatti who where is he now oh
actually he's in prison so this is the
Crux of the case that you're building
and I got to tell you
you're putting Donald Trump's life in
danger
you're setting him up and advertising
the entire world the former president of
the United States the Republican nominee
for the presidency is going to be at
this location at this time on this date
and you've got towers and you've got
Windows oh my God you think that's good
for this country to put a man like that
in a certain location
December 4th and then what if it goes to
trial he has to be there every day you
think the Secret Service wants that
that is dangerous and he is playing a
dangerous game that's a Monday by the
way it might be a good day to take off
in this city after you saw everything
today Jesse is officially in the come on
man category all right we're going to
put him down for that hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now